we're told sugar is freely traded in the
world market assume that a country
lorryland is a price taker in the world
market for sugar some of the sugar
consumed in lower land is produced
domestically while the rest is imported
the world price of sugar is two dollars
per pound the graph below shows lower
lands sugar market and p sub w
represents the world price so we see our
domestic demand we see our domestic
supply and then we see the world price
all right now let's try to answer the
questions that they
have given us
at the world price of two dollars per
pound how much sugar is loreland
importing so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out on your own
all right now let's do it together
so at first you look at your domestic
demand and see well what would the
domestic demand be at the world price so
that would be where these two lines
intersect so the domestic demand at the
world price would be 14 million pounds
you might be tempted to put 14 million
pounds here but that would be the total
domestic demand at the world price but
some of that is domestically produced
and some of it is imported how much is
domestically produced well at a price of
two dollars the domestic producers are
up for producing 2 million of those 14
million pounds so this is domestic
production and so between these two
points
that length that represents how much is
actually imported so to go from 2
million pounds to 14 million pounds 14
minus 2 is 12 million pounds that is
imported 12 million
pounds part b
suppose that lower land imposes a per
unit tariff on sugar imports and the new
domestic price including the tariff is
four dollars
identify the new level of domestic
production so once again pause the video
and try to figure that out
all right so they say the new domestic
price including the tariff is four
dollars so we are now in this situation
this is the new
price
now they say what is the new level of
domestic production so the domestic
supply at that price the domestic
suppliers
look like they are willing to supply 6
million pounds so that is our new level
of domestic production 6 million
pounds
all right part 2 calculate the domestic
consumer surplus for lower land you must
show your work pause the video and see
if you can figure that out
well the domestic consumer surplus for
lower land in this scenario where this
is the price well then we are going to
let me scroll down a little bit so we
can see the entire consumer surplus that
is going to be the area
above this horizontal line at the price
and below our domestic demand curve so
this right over here is the consumer
surplus in that scenario and so that is
going to be this width which is the
quantity demanded which is 10 million
pounds
times the height which is you're going
from four to nine dollars so it has a
height of five dollars
and then times one half if i just
multiplied the quantity times the height
i'd be figuring out the area of this
entire rectangle so it's a little bit of
geometry review to get half of that we
would multiply by half
so this is going to be it's going to be
10 million pounds i'll do it right over
here so if some space 10 million
pounds
times we have a difference of five
dollars per pound
five
dollars per
pound and then of course we want to
multiply it times one half so this one
right over here so let's see the pounds
cancel out and so if you multiply it out
this is going to be 50 million dollars
times one half so it's going to be 25
million dollars
all right part three scroll down a
little bit
calculate the total tariff revenue
collected by the government this also
says you must show your work once again
pause the video and see if you can work
through that
so the tariff revenue collected by the
government well we went from a world
price of two dollars per pound to a
domestic price of four dollars per pound
so it was a two dollar per pound tariff
and the government is collecting that
two dollars per pound on the imports so
in this situation this is the domestic
supply we've already talked about that
and so this amount right over here are
the imports so if you multiply this
amount which went from 6 million pounds
to 10 million pounds so this is going to
be 4 million pounds times the tariff
which is two dollars
per pound
per
pound
you're going to get this area which
would be the government revenue so this
is going to be
four
million pounds
times two dollars per pound
times two dollars per pound pound
cancels out and this is an area of a
rectangle here and so this is going to
be equal to eight
million
eight million dollars
all right now let's do part c
given the world price of two dollars
what per unit tariff maximizes the sum
of loreland's domestic consumer surplus
and producer surplus pause the video
once more and see if you can figure this
out
all right so you might be tempted to try
out a bunch of tariffs and figure out if
you can get a higher total surplus but
the important thing to realize is any
tariff is going to reduce your total
economic surplus so you can immediately
go and say that hey the ideal per unit
tariff is going to be zero dollars per
unit
and if you want to see visually why that
is we talk about in other videos
remember in the first situation where we
are just at the world price without any
terrorists the total economic surplus
this is the domestic producer surplus
which isn't that much but you have a
huge consumer surplus
you have all of this area as well
so those two triangles make the total
economic surplus now tariff is going to
raise this level
and as you raise this level as you saw
in the case of part b
well you're going to shrink this upper
triangle you will grow this bottom
triangle but you're still going to be
smaller than your two triangles that you
had before because look at that second
scenario the scenario in part b
your consumer surplus has now shrunk to
this right over here your producer
surplus has grown to that over there
but you haven't
grown the total surplus in fact now for
the consumers and the producers you've
lost this entire triangle some of it is
captured by government revenue but you
also have
dead weight loss you also just have this
section and this section as just
deadweight laws and so any tariff is
going to reduce the is going to reduce
your possible economic surplus so a zero
dollar tariff theoretically would
maximize your total economic surplus